last week i told you about two
republicans who said
it's too much with the shootings
we need
gun control i'm open
to an assault weapons ban that was adam
kinzinger republican congressman who's
outgoing and new york's chris jacobs
one of those two republicans has now
been so shunned by the republican party
that has withdrawn their support for him
that he now has announced he's not going
to be running for re-election that's it
you're off script and you're gone so
reminder last week i did a story called
multiple republicans change their minds
open to banning assault rifles
and they weren't like huge lefty
declarations it was just hey you know
i've opposed these types of bans in the
past
but we sort of have to do something
because this isn't good
and one of those republicans was chris
jacobs from new york he is now done
here's a report from the hill
new york republican won't run for second
term after backing gun control
representative chris jacobs on friday
announced he will not run for a second
term in the house one week after
breaking from his party and announcing
his support for an assault weapons ban
jacobs who represents suburbs of buffalo
said today i'm announcing i will not run
for the 23rd congressional district i
will finish out my time as a member of
congress to the end of this year
jacobs was endorsed by the nra in 2020
announced he would support a bill to ban
assault style rifles if it came to the
floor adam kinzinger who's retiring said
the same thing
jacobs also backed raising the required
age for specific gun sales to 21 years
old i'd say 25 but 21 something enacting
a federal limit on gun magazine
capacities i agree and prohibiting the
sale of body armor to the public the new
york republican told the buffalo news in
an interview that he reconsidered his
point of view toward guns after the
shootings in buffalo and uvalde texas
makes sense
uh jacobs on friday said every
republican elected official who endorsed
him in his re-election bid has withdrawn
their support since he backed gun
control measures last week he also said
he lost the backing of republican
committees and the republican and
conservative parties in new york state
the congressman said he ultimately
decided to back out of the race to avoid
an incredibly divisive election despite
the backlash i truly believe i could win
but it would be incredibly divisive for
the party and the people of the 23rd
district many of whom i have not ever
represented
this is because the redistricting would
move him from the 27th to the 23rd
district saying he doesn't want a
campaign filled with half-truths and
lies so look at that he merely
entertains an assault weapons ban and he
is excommunicated by the party and is
driven out of office now i know some
people will say but david he chose to
quit okay but the message here is
if you aren't on message we all pull our
support we endorse your opponent you're
on your own there's no gray area on this
issue you're either on script or you
were off script it's a form of
you guys know what it is right
it's a form of cancel culture
you say one wrong thing
and you're out
and any sort of moderation
puts you in a precarious position in
today's republican party it's not a big
tent party there i mean think of it liz
cheney all she said was trump genuinely
lost biden genuinely won trump did have
a role in inciting the insurrection
she's on a list she gets primaried trump
shows up and campaigns for her opponent
so this is how they work don't let them
trick you into believing
that the cancel culture is on the left
they will cancel you
if you go off script right away and this
is evidence of it so the two thing to
think of it the two republicans who have
said hey you know what
this was my view before
but here's my view now
um kenzinger is saying it with the
safety of knowing he's retiring anyway
and jacobs now is saying whoa this got
crazy i'm bailing
sad commentary on the state of the
republican party